i'm tammy bruce i'm juan williams i'm
shannon breme and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday october 20th 2021 i'm lisa
brady over 200 million americans have
received at least one dose of coba
vaccine employees who still don't want
it may face a losing battle in court as
a general rule i think courts are going
to be supportive of companies adopting
these types of vaccine requirements
including boosters
i'm dave anthony we've all heard a lot
of bad stuff about the trump white house
today a much different view from an
advisor who was there all four years and
has a new book and i wanted america to
see because it's a different type of
person that was portrayed in the press
out there and they've got it wrong
because i saw him i mean i saw him for
longer than anybody else in the white
house in the national security realm
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
forced to choose between getting a
coveted shot or losing their job some
people are walking away including
essential workers we worked 18 months
without having any type of issues and
now suddenly we have to have these
mandatory vaccines robert lemay resigned
after 22 years as a state trooper in
washington state and says there was no
question about his decision not to take
the vaccine the process how they did it
was ridiculous and making people do this
or you're losing your job was ridiculous
washington's vaccine mandate for state
employees does not include a testing
option it does include a religious
exemption but lemay says he was
ultimately told he'd have to switch jobs
take a pay cut and potentially move
chicago is beginning to withhold pay
from unvaccinated police officers and
lawsuits have been filed over the city's
vaccine mandate top white house covet
advisor dr anthony fauci was asked by
fox news sunday host chris wallace about
the potential public safety impact of
police pilots and health workers
threatening walkouts and whether
mandates should continue to be enforced
in those cases we know now the
statistics more police officers die of
covid than they do in other causes of
death so
it doesn't make any sense to not trying
to protect yourself
as well as the colleagues that you work
with pouchy says he's not comfortable
telling people what to do in normal
circumstances but that these aren't
normal circumstances and as private
employers face a new federal rule for
vaccination or testing the courts so far
have not been kind to mandate
challengers part of the reason for
the poor record on challenges is that
the supreme court
many years ago
accepted a state vaccine mandate in
massachusetts that is still governing
authority jonathan turley is a law
professor at george washington
university and a fox news contributor
the courts are following that jacobson
case particularly when it is a state
mandate it gets a little tougher
if it's a federal mandate there's very
good arguments against the suggestion of
the bite administration that they could
just
impose a mandate and i think the byte
administration has pretty much
recognized that because when they went
with the
current mandate they filtered it through
the department of labor as an osha or
workplace requirement and that was very
clever but it was really an effort to
avoid this issue
that they're just treating this as part
of the mandate to
guarantee workplace safety
now whether that succeeds or not we'll
see but it's a stronger basis than just
imposing a direct mandate so this is a
public health issue and courts tend to
defer to the states
and they also have the support of the
cdc and so judges are very reluctant to
countermand or disagree with the cdc
they're likely to accept the view of the
cdc that this is a necessary public
health measure
some of the mandates are facing some
very detailed
arguments for instance pilots suing
southwest arguing the airline is
supposed to maintain the same working
conditions rates of pay and rules
while the union's negotiating a new
contract
does a case like that have a better
chance of succeeding you know i still
think that the airlines have a stronger
case there the strongest cases in my
view
involve those raising religious
exemptions there's now a building
movement to refuse even exemptions on
the basis of religion
that i think could have much greater
success in the courts
there's also this question of natural
antibodies you know there are
studies out there that show that
recovering from covid gives you
the same if if not better
uh protection than a vaccine
if that's true and i can't really speak
to the science
the courts would be in a really tough
position if you don't allow antibodies
to be considered because then basically
what the states would be arguing is we
don't have the time to sort people out
you know the reason we're requiring
vaccines is because administratively
it's very hard to distinguish well where
are you in terms of your natural
antibodies
that doesn't really hold very well right
because you have the same problem with
vaccines people tend to have dropping
protection over time from their vaccines
and you can test antibodies like you can
test
if someone has covet
so i think that that's another area that
the science may be complicating the
legal basis of these states
what about this issue of religious
exemptions how do you prove a sincerely
held religious exemption well of course
that's a problem that we deal with all
the time because many people
ask for exemptions from taxation and
other forms of government obligations
sometimes the government challenges that
it happens all the time in the irs i
wrote a piece many decades ago uh
on this very issue for the academic
press
because it is
those of us who teach constitutional law
grapple with
how do you define a legitimate religion
but there's actually an office in the
internal revenue service that just does
this matter factly every day right
there's a bureaucrat that sits there and
goes no that's fraudulent this is not
that's fraudulent this is not and
i
they have to make that decision because
people are exempting themselves from
taxation or other obligations so the
courts have to make that decision so how
do they do it well they look at whether
it's a recognized religion even if it's
not a recognized
more sort of marginalized religion they
look at
a proven
or sort of demonstration of faith
through having a structure to your
religion or rules or recognized
sort of procedures of your religion so
it's a case by case to certain decision
that courts have to make
some faith leaders have very publicly
come forward though and said look our
religion really has nothing against
vaccines
um so when that happens
does that sort of blow the exemption
argument out of the water if if the
leader of your particular church or
religion is saying no
really we have no vaccine
objections
yeah that really does undermine it uh
but the problem is that
you can still have religious beliefs
different from
your church hierarchy then the court is
in the position of trying to decide
whether this is still a bona fide
religious belief even if it's not
supported by the church hierarchy
a good example of that is the mormon
church had a lot of fractures on
polygamy there are some groups that that
would spin off from the mormon church on
plural unions
but they were still following religious
views
so
i don't think that would end the issue
um it would make it a little more
difficult
to prevail but i don't think that the
court should just simply disregard a
religious claim because the
uh hierarchy of the church does not
agree with that interpretation
seattle and chicago are two of the big
cities that have become real flash
points for the issue of police
especially who aren't vaccinated and who
may lose their jobs or lose pay or
lose benefits if they try to resign over
this vaccination issue in chicago though
the police union leader
zeroed in on the portal where city
employees are supposed to report
vaccination status
raising a broader concern about sharing
medical information
what about that as a strategy to fight
the mandate yeah that's a very
interesting claim because as you know we
have a number of saving federal laws
protecting
medical information
i i'm not too sure why the city requires
that portal it seems like an easy thing
for the city to
resolve
even if they're going to confirm
vaccinated status but there's also just
a public policy question the question is
with
deaths dropping
do
governments both state and federal still
want to create these bright line rules
you know i talked to a
a physician uh in new york who
uh was really he's very pro vaccine he's
he's a very well recognized
figure in the field but he was apoplexic
i mean he
he was they were looking at getting rid
of about 20 of their staff
doctors and nurses who didn't want to
take the vaccine many of them have
recovered from covet and they don't see
the reason for doing so when they have
natural antibodies and he was he was
telling me what are we supposed to do
you know we can't just lose 20 percent
of our staff
and i think that that's something that
is worth the public debate you know is
this
uh approach which is a very bright line
the only way that you can proceed in
this respect
is any of this any different for
professional athletes from a legal
standpoint because obviously not
everyone with a job has a contract
but let's say if someone like kyrie
irving of the brooklyn nets who's not
vaccinated and is now benched
what would happen if he sued or for not
being able to play and losing a lot of
his pay in the process
no i don't think there is a difference
he is a private employee
and
private employers are being asked to
maintain this bright line and to require
vaccinations if anything these sports
teams are in a better position because
they are
mandating a vaccine in areas where
people are in close contact there's
heavy breathing
uh
you know it's not like
you know some other sports where people
are separated so
you know they could make
medical based arguments that it's even
more important for them as a private
employer to have this rule but as a
general matter as you know private
employers are in very good position
requiring
these rules
if
vaccine mandates continue to hold up
legally
will employers then have the power to
also demand booster shots yes i mean i
think that they very well could they i
once again these employers could argue
that they're trying to make this the
workplace as safe as possible
even though the
necessity of booster shocks may not have
been established so far there's a lot we
don't know
about boosters how long
these vaccines are remaining viable in
terms of protection also we have the
declining numbers of cases in many
states but also we have a lot of
unknowns with regards to the variant the
breakthrough cases will the
boosters
have this type of effect against some of
these new
variants we even have a new variant
coming out of
england which is worrying a lot of folks
so there's a lot of moving parts here
but
as a general rule i think courts are
going to be supportive of companies
adopting
these types of vaccine requirements
including boosters particularly when the
cdc is behind them i mean the cdc is the
big dog on the block when it comes to
court review
jonathan turley george washington
university law professor and fox news
contributor thank you very much for your
time
my great pleasure
[Music]
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
he was there from almost the beginning i
am officially running
for president of the united states not
long after donald trump entered the race
keith kellogg a retired army lieutenant
general joined the republicans campaign
as an advisor then after the 2016 trump
victory he went to the white house as
part of the national security team and
stayed there to the bitter end january
20th and i can tell you that from the
bottom of my heart this has been an
incredible four years now general keith
kellogg has written a book about it all
things started in the actuals in the
oval office of the president said you
know he looked at me and said you've
been with me longer than anybody else
has you ought to write a book you've
seen it all the books out this week
titled war by other means a general in
the trump white house i saw a president
that the people don't see and when the
clique lights come on it's a different
president when people think about his
hard tweets but you know when i was with
him dave i saw the way he felt about
america he's unabashedly you know
pro-american he loves america loves our
military going forward he's wicked smart
he's instincts are incredible or off the
charts on what he wants to do he makes
decisions rapidly and they're good hard
decisions and he sticks with those
decisions through thick or thin and i
wanted america to see because it's a
different type of person that was
portrayed in the press out there and
they've got it wrong because i saw him i
mean i saw him for
longer than anybody else in the white
house in the national security realm you
wrote yes he can be profane yes he's
willing to say publicly things many of
us would only say in private yes he can
be aggressive but then you write about
how he's candid you wrote to a fault and
caring in a way that most people didn't
see
a lot of people listening and a lot of
people who certainly would have never
voted for him
just don't
imagine that that person exists yeah you
know
here's who in the middle of the cove i
didn't know the outbreak going there we
were sitting in the oval one day and we
were just talking because sometimes i
just stand around put my hand on the
couch and just sit there and bs with him
in newton
and he looked at me and said you know i
just want americans to get better just
in that tone of voice i said mr
president go out and say that right now
the american people and he goes no no no
he said you know what the american
people wanted one expect the leader to
be very very strong going forward he
said but that's how i feel i know that's
how he felt about it
you
wanted to be part of his campaign you
reached out and then it worked out that
you were an advisor to to candidate
trump and then you stayed the whole time
all the way to the last day of the
administration and we'll get to january
6th but but
why why there the whole time so many
people don't stick around they stay they
get burnt out there's a lot of effort
there's a lot of work
obviously disagreement at times
we were constantly under siege you know
from before we even became into the
administration started
people were against us from the very
start and i don't care if it was
russiagate or whatever it was out there
but he was always trying to do good
things and i said you know this is a man
i want to stay with and i've always
believed in loyalty and it's a very very
hard predicate for me
that you know if as long as you have
loyalty and staying with person even
people even if you don't agree with him
and he would allow me to disagree with
him all the time if i didn't say you
know agree with what he was saying or
doing that i'd say to him and he bought
into that but i wouldn't go public with
it and you know
people need to tell me okay i know you
don't like his hard tweets or what he
said that was a big part of it but tell
me tell me the bad policies we had i
can't find anybody who's telling me our
policies are bad
but style sometimes matters a lot more
than substance to some people and
were there times that that he would say
something that was brash or tweet
something that was
what people thought was over the line
that you yourself were would say oh why
did he do that
yeah i i would and and if i thought
something i had to go in there and say
i'd make a comment to him about it but i
also understood one thing that there
were times that people didn't understand
he was the president of the united
states he got more electoral votes than
i did i didn't get any people need to
understand this is a man who actually
did listen and he had a very socratic
way of doing it he'd go around the room
and ask questions and he would force you
to defend your position and if you
defended your positions well he may not
like it but he would accept it and he
did that on several occasions you know
though others have have
said oh you know he ignored advice or he
was disinterested in briefings and then
he would say a company well i'm i know
more than arms smarter than the generals
or something like that
which which undercuts what you're saying
that he was engaged in all these
briefings was he always engaged in the
briefings now he was he was always there
he was a very very prolific reader when
we used to travel during the campaign he
would read the wall street journal he'd
read the new york times he'd read the
washington post he'd read the financial
times going forward in a local newspaper
as well he would always read and go
through them and he would read the
articles and he'd circle these articles
and he'd rip him out of the paper and
put him on a box next to him and he
would keep this box of notes that he'd
taken to himself and he was
exceptionally well-read and so when
people say wasn't word of red i said
baloney
there was a caricature though general of
a guy who just
watched cable news all day
and uh you know he would try to hire a
fox commentator or fox contributor
because he's watching fox all day and
and and that you know all this executive
time and he was golfing all the time you
know that that's that's that's another
of the things that people had said about
the president but he was a funnel awful
long time in the oval office too sitting
around talking long meetings not short
meetings long ones so when people said
that said okay yeah people they watch tv
sure but would you well read sure and
you know they'd have to tell people okay
i kind of seen a word where people
didn't see that so that's the reason i
want one of the reasons i wrote the book
and also why i'm so comfortable talking
about it because i was there they
weren't in the room i was
you shifted though
from being an advisor to president trump
to vice president pence and i thought it
was very interesting that uh you wrote
in the book that the secret service had
their own codes for the president and
vice president but you had yours and
yours show the differences between the
two men yeah it might you know it was
his nickname by the secretaries was
mogul and the vice president was hoosier
from the state of indiana i called him
fire and ice and i said because it was
so different between the two of them and
the president was very dynamic very when
i say on fire
you operate in what i'd call as a trump
time when he wanted something once i'm
done down give me the reason why we're
not doing it right away why we're
pushing by the way that's one of the
reasons why we got three vaccines in
record time because of covid because he
pushed everybody to get there if we'd
rather normal bureaucratic process we'd
still be looking for a coveted vaccine
going forward
mike pence on the other time was very
reserved very laid back and in the sense
laid back he was very
he would never come out and push things
in a very vocal and hard manner in fact
the entire time i was with vice
president pence i never heard him swear
one time i mean i would get three swear
words out of the present within an hour
you know and it was just that they're
different styles but and they were
complementary styles
then came january 6th when president
trump who insisted the election was
stolen by fraud he was unable to prove
in court told a rally it was up to
republicans in congress to fix this
egregious assault on our democracy and
after this
we're going to walk down to the capitol
and we're going to cheer on
our brave senators and
congressmen and women but that's not
what happened
[Applause]
trump supporters stormed the capitol an
attack that halted the election
certification
but hours after they were cleared out it
resumed and early in the next morning
vice president pence did not challenge
the results joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes making him president-elect
then president trump was impeached again
accused of inciting what democrats
called an insurrection
look that was not an insurrection okay
that was a riot gone bad and when they
had gone down there we didn't know that
was going on until we got back to the
oval office so we saw it on tv and the
vice president we we kept very good
track of the president asked me during
all of this where the vice president was
i and i had good control of where he was
at because i was talking to the secret
service at the same time because we had
an ability to talk to them uh and i knew
exactly where he was at it was in the
basement of the senate building so we
saw that going on there was an
unfortunate day but anybody who said
russia come on i i've seen worse riots
going on and that was it to me a riot
going bad but during it for hours didn't
hear much from the president and then he
made like a taped speech
and he seemed to in it
praise at least
or at least
acknowledge that the support that he was
getting from these people and that
didn't go over very well either did you
at all sense that he wasn't involved in
trying to stop the ride that he didn't
no not at all in fact when this thing
first started
he is the one who said to him to the
chief of staff of the white house and i
was there in the out of the oval
when mark meadows came out and said
where's the national guard looked at me
and said that and we found that they
were supposed to be national guard on
the streets and what happened was
that the defense department held them up
because they didn't like the quote
optics of that going forward look if we
had the intelligence this was going to
go bad don't you think the capitol
police would have upgraded don't you
think the uh the u.s marshals service
would have upgraded at the time none of
them were ready for it and they're
prepared for it so we had to react to it
and anytime you get into a situation
like that when you're reacting something
you're already behind the curve have you
been asked by the house select committee
investigating to testify not yet but i'm
sure my name's all this time sure they
haven't yet i think they're talking to a
lot of others but i'm ready to it and
it's sort of like i'm like i did with
the mueller commission as well you know
i was the first one in the white house
to go talk to the mueller commission you
know when and i said i'm willing to do
it and i'm going to go there you know
candidly i'm going to go up there with a
lawyer too i don't need a lawyer i tell
them exactly what i saw what i heard
well in his book that just came out
tuesday general kellogg goes into detail
also about president trump's plan to end
the war in afghanistan and he's critical
of the chaotic withdrawal under
president biden demanding someone be
held accountable calling for a 9 11 type
commission to investigate
yeah i just think the whole 20-year
warranty was looked at actually 18-year
war because the first two years to me
were righteous when you go after
al-qaeda you go after bin laden and the
rest of them that's a righteous kind of
war but the last 18 years we were doing
something we shouldn't have ever been
doing which is nation building and we're
involved in tribal warfare we have
thousands killed
thousands more wounded
hundreds of billions dollars have spent
and we lost a war and now just oh well
okay what are we having for breakfast
tomorrow that's wrong i wanted to get
out because one of the concerns i had
talking to president trump even when he
was a candidate was until we disengaged
ourselves from the middle east keep
focused there but not total focus we can
then focus on the russians and the
chinese
and especially with the chinese look the
reason they have hypersonic weapons
and we don't is we took our eye off the
r d ball because well then we're not
worried about that well we should look
what's happened now they've got
hypersonic weapons that by the way when
i say hypersonic most people go okay
they've got a hypersonic weapon this is
mach 5 and higher this is a system that
flies a mile in two seconds or less you
can tip it with a conventional warhead
or a nuclear warhead going forward and
they've got them and we're still in the
r d phase okay that's a game changer the
book is war by other means a general in
the trump white house from former
national security adviser for both
president trump and vice president pence
now retired lieutenant general keith
kellogg
again congratulations on your book and
thank you very much for joining us today
i thank you thanks for having me i do
appreciate it
[Music]
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast there's part of a
colorful late 90s imac on mars it's an
idea that seems a lot like kickstarter
called build it subscribe and listen now
by going to foxnewspodcast.com or
wherever you get your podcasts subscribe
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind for a good reason
there have been more than a few
references in social media to the truman
show a 1998 jim carrey film about a man
living what he thinks is a totally
normal life but in fact is a completely
contrived reality show he slowly grows
to realize that his friends family and
everyone else populating his life are
actors with thousands of cameras
secreted throughout his town filming
everything he does for a worldwide
audience in the late 1990s everyone
considered the premise absurd fast
forward to the 21st century and reality
television is standard fare but it's the
biden administration's behavior that has
reminded us of what it's like to be
presented with something that is meant
to appear as real and natural but is
nothing other than orchestrated and
contrived things you see that are
supposed to be genuine are instead fake
sets with fake actors delivered by fake
news
at first it was the bizarre revelation
that the biden administration had
constructed a set
across the street from the white house
to be used in place of the oval office
east room and well any other white house
location for a public statement or
meeting it was constructed to give the
appearance that mr biden is in the white
house
which he leaves to go to the fake set
of the same building
stephen miller the founder of america
first legal proposed quote the reason
biden uses this bizarre virtual set for
televised meetings and not an actual
room like the east room cabinet oval
roosevelt situation room etc
is because it allows him to read a
script directly from a face on monitor
well it's fair to say this sort of
perplexing development only heightens
americans concern about whether mr biden
can run the country and increases
anxiety about his administration
appearing to rely on lies as opposed to
the transparency and clarity we all
demand
contrived situations sets and scripts
aren't just for joe biden vice president
kamala harris is also into the act as
multiple crises continue to unfold in
the united states the vice president of
border election integrity space forces r
kamala decided her time would be best
spent participating in a video for a
youtube original series called get
curious promoting space and science to
kids
inexplicably it seems everything miss
harris does becomes a disaster and this
was no different the video was mocked as
bizarre with her expressions and
delivery exaggerated
and manufactured just when you think it
can't get any worse we find it can with
the biden harris crowd after the
withering criticism of her space video
behavior it was revealed that the kids
involved were all actors
the entire thing was fake the reliance
on control and theater is now so
integral for this gang everything has to
be scripted every word must be
controlled ironically their handlers
don't realize that in their frenzy to
demonstrate that mr biden and miss
harris are genuine caring and competent
they expose them as none of the above
have we missed the mark this entire time
by not considering that the swampy
bureaucracy running the biden-harris
show
actually views mr biden and miss harris
is nothing more than actors
in all fairness while they work
diligently to ruin our futures miss
harris may be thinking about her next
act like mr and mrs obama she could be
eyeing the money and power in hollywood
it would be good for her to have a plan
b if this audition for acting president
doesn't work out maybe she could star in
a reboot of the television show veep
she's certainly ready for that
this is tammy bruce host of get tammy
bruce now streaming on fox nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes